pas de fatalité ni aux grandes et
classement ni au grand remplacement plus
long placement réalisé de population et
celle du grand remplacement on entend
beaucoup parler de grand remplacement ce
dernier temps mais qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
ces mythomanes bonjour l'aiea le grand
remplacement c'est une expression qui a
été inventé par un écrivain d'extrême
droite renaud camus ça sert à désigner
un phénomène de substitution
démographique en gros bas les
populations européennes seraient sur le
point d'être submergée par l'immigration
en provenance d'afrique et du maghreb et
d'ici quelques décennies elles seraient
remplacées par des populations de
culture musulmane donc à ce stade ce que
tu me dis c'est qu'on ne sait pas
combien il y aura de français musulmans
dans 50 ans les projections
démographiques les plus réalistes parle
d'une population musulmane en france
d'environ 18 % en 2050 mais il ya des
variables comme le solde migratoire où
le taux de fécondité sur lequel il est
très compliqué voire impossible
d'extrapoler au delà d'une période
donnée tu sais les musulmans c'est pas
un groupe homogène c'est un ensemble
divers d'individus qui ont pour point
commun d'avoir la même religion points
l'idée qu'il formerait un bloc que
chaque personne se reconnaissant dans
cette religion ou ayant un lien avec
cette religion serait comme l'agent d'un
grand projet subversif pas cela ça va au
delà du complotisme c'est du racisme du
racisme mais on parle de religion même
si on parle de religion c'est du racisme
parce que c'est une manière
d'essentialiser les gens de les assigner
à une identité et à une seule c'est une
idée qui par exemple suggère que si on
est musulman on peut pas être vraiment
français or dans notre république mais
on est libre de croire ou de ne pas
croire et surtout de croire à ce qu'on
veut l'idée que cette religion en
particulier serait incompatible avec la
république mais ça va pas du tout soit
ou alors faut expliquer à nos
compatriotes musulmans que ceux de leurs
ancêtres qui ont combattu et qui sont
même parfois morts pour la france eh ben
ils sont pas compatibles avec notre pays
mais le grand remplacement c'est juste
une théorie non oui mais c'est au nom de
cette théorie qu'il ya eu plusieurs
massacres par exemple brendan torrent le
terroriste qui a massacré plus de 50
musulmans à christchurch en nouvelle
zélande en 2019 eh bien il a commis son
crime au nom du grand remplacement
anders breivik qui lui a tué 80
personnes à oslo et bien séparés et
pourquoi grand remplacement c'est une
terminologie violente
l'adjectif grand déjà il sert dramatiser
l'enjeu a laissé entendre qu'on va être
submergé par un tsunami migratoire et
démographique et puis il ya le mot
remplacement par les deux remplacements
ça suggère que les nouvelles populations
au lieu de s'additionner à celle qui
sont déjà là elles viennent se
substituer à elle dans les faits il n'y
a pas de remplacement mais une
cohabitation et souvent même un mélange
un métissage les êtres humains de
cultures différentes sont pas comme de
l'huile et de l'eau ils vivent ensemble
ils vont à l'école ensemble ils
travaillent ensemble et parfois ils font
même des enfants ensemble
[Musique]